des sondes qui on doit entre animalité
et onirisme et et qu'elle en 2003 c'est
c'est ça
les gens déjà à l'époque savais pas trop
comment nous qualifier parce que ça
ressemblait pas grand chose je crois
quand on a commencé la musique tous
ensemble on savait pas jouer en fait
ici avec int en formation rock machine
ezéchiel on invitait des groupes mais
aussi tenter des expériences comme celle
avec leur caisse du grand théâtre de
tours
mais
enfin
en 2003 yann le bassiste profite de la
tournée extended pour quitter la scène
et se focaliser sur les visuels
l'idée lors du première c'était
d'arrêter de faire une image au sens
figuratif comment fait depuis 15 ans
avec un bel écran sur scène et une belle
image bien léché bien barreau via
poétique pour essayer de d'innover de
surprendre un peu donc il sait
travailler des choses un peu plus
abstraite et surtout transformé la scène
en images
le gros danger c'est réglé tout le monde
parce que c'est assez puissant et donc
du coup aussi venu avec l'expérience on
s'est rendu compte qu'il fallait jamais
toutes allumées toutes les lèvres en
même temps qu'il fallait jamais bon le
fait une ou deux fois volontairement
mettre les lettres face au public parce
que ça fait un flash donc mes vingt
secondes 30 secondes à 100 m avec leur
dixième album ezéchiel montre encore une
fois son côté laboratoire et fait table
rase du passé vont se lancer dans
quelque chose oui quelque part
d'expérimental pour nous aussi en terme
de musique c'est à dire qu'on a des on a
des idées move on va faire des choses
qu'on n'a jamais faites encore toute
façon n'est pas tombé dans une
répétition une resucée d'un album
précédent
on défend un album dont on n'est pas
encore là c'est parce que ça ça arrive
vite faire la maj parle pour moi là
c'est tout nouveau ça fait ça fait
vraiment du bien
des riffs incendiaire aux ambiances
contemplative eh les gars comment faites
vous au bout de plus de 20 ans de
carrière pour toujours nous envoûte et
on ajuste passionné par ce qu'on fait et
puis
voilà
cdc aussi des des compromis d
et comme dans un couple en fait sauf que
nous on fait pas le mois mai